la contraofensiva del ejército ucraniano
sigue en la región de jarc y donde nos
encontramos estamos en malaya arrojan
este pueblo estuvo ocupado por las
tropas rusas hace apenas unas semanas y
aquí hay restos de esa batalla que se
produjo ya lo pueden ver un carro de
combate ruso totalmente calcinado el
pueblo estaba prácticamente destrozado y
los vecinos que quedan son los que
aguantaron durante esos intensos
bombardeos desde aquí se disparaba
directamente a la ciudad de kharkiv la
guerra continúa aquí y los principales
frentes están en la zona sur de jarc y
frontera con lugar el gobierno ruso ha
informado de que tiene el control de
toda la zona de lugar pero donges sigue
estando en disputa a todos esos terrenos
aquí seguimos estando en primera línea a
40 kilómetros en y si se siguen
produciendo batallas muy intensas y
hasta aquí sigue llegando la artillería
rusa de hecho hace apenas unos minutos
durante esta mañana hemos estado
escuchando helicóptero super ya nos que
están dando soporte a todos esos
enfrentamientos que se están produciendo
ahora mismo
la zona sur de la región dejar 15 donde
estamos ahora mismo